what I want to do in this video is
analyze why it makes sense for two
companies that make up a duopoly do ah
Polly to coordinate to get into an
agreement which may or may not be legal
probably would be illegal and restrict
quantity but also think about why
there's a strong incentive for either or
both of the parties to cheat their
agreement and produce more quantity than
they agreed to produce so let's say that
this is that both of our players in our
duopoly and this would actually apply to
an oligopoly generally but the analysis
would be a little bit more difficult if
we had more than two players but let's
say each player has an identical they're
identical companies and they both have a
marginal cost curve that looks something
like that so they both have a marginal
cost curve an individual marginal cost
curve that looks like that and they both
have an average total cost curve that
looks something like this so they both
have an average total cost curve average
total cost curve that looks something
like that and they are identical so I'll
just draw it once this is the marginal
cost and average total cost for both
firms now let's think about what it
would look like for the market well one
way to think about it one way to think
about it pick and pick an arbitrary and
arbitrary marginal cost so for one firm
what can they produce at or what
quantity will they be at that marginal
cost well there'll be at this quantity
for that marginal cost but if you have
two firms that are just like that they
could have twice as much quantity at
that to be at that point in marginal
cost so two firms will be over there and
if you picked this marginal cost one
firm would produce that quantity to be
right at that marginal cost for that
next incremental good but two firms
could produce two especially if that the
exact same cost structure could produce
two so what you're going to have is
you're essentially adding this curve to
itself in the horizontal direction so if
you look at the marginal cost curve for
both firms together you're essentially
going to get a curve that is twice as
fat as the marginal cost curve for one
firm so it will look something like this
and I'll do it in yellow so it will look
something like that so that is the
marginal cost for the market
where the market in this example is both
of these farms and the average that that
will also be true for the average total
cost if if at this price right or
actually I should say if the average
total cost is up here for one firm that
means that they are producing this
quantity but two firms together could
provide twice the quantity of that
average total qua cause so two firms
would produce twice and so what you're
going to have is an average total cost
curve that is twice as fat as the
average total cost curve for one firm if
you talk about the market so the markets
average total cost curve is going to
look something like this it's going to
be twice as fat the exact same logic
it's going to look something something
like that so that is the average total
cost curve for for the market so so far
the convention that I've ended up using
is orange for an individual firm and
then this dotted yellow line for the
market as a whole now let's think about
what the equilibrium per hour let what
of what what the right price should be
if they were able to coordinate if they
were to able be able to coordinate
together if they were essentially
combined their firms and almost behave
like a monopoly and to think about that
we're going to have to draw a demand
curve so let me draw the market demand
curve let's say the market demand curve
looks something like that it's really
big so it's hard for me and we'll assume
that this is a line so it's not well
that's pretty good so this is the market
demand curve market demand demand curve
so if both of these firms operated
together if they and I have often if I
drew the market demand curve I also want
to draw the market marginal revenue
curve now remember we're going to assume
that both of these firms are acting
together if they perfectly coordinate
they can join their capacities and act
essentially like a monopoly so if we're
if they did act like a monopoly their
marginal revenue curve would be twice
the slope of this market demand curve so
it would hit the horizontal axis right
over there and so it would look
something like this
it would look something like that so
that is the this right over here is the
market this is the market marginal
revenue marginal revenue curve so if
they were to behave like a monopoly you
could view this dotted line as their
marginal cost curve this would be their
average total cost and now this is their
marginal revenue if they were to behave
as a monopoly what would be the optimal
quantity will be right there right where
marginal revenue is equal to marginal
cost before that they keep wanting to
produce because marginal revenue is
higher than marginal quantity or the
marginal revenue is higher than marginal
cost and then after that they don't want
to produce because marginal cost is
higher than marginal revenue and they're
going to take economic losses on each of
those incremental units and so this is
the quantity that they would produce and
the price they would get for that they
just have to go to the market demand
curve they would get this price this
price right over here let's say they
would get that price right over there
and the actual their average total cost
per unit once again we have to go to the
market here we're behaving it's this
dotted line right over here that is
their average total cost per unit so
their average economic profit per unit
is going to be their revenue per unit
minus their average total cost per unit
so this is right this this height is
their economic profit per unit and if we
if we multiply that times the total
number of units you would get you would
get their total economic profit if they
coordinate perfectly essentially
behaving essentially behaving like a
monopoly and let's just say for argument
that this height right over here let's
say that that is ten and let's say that
this quantity this quantity that they
would they would want to produce as a
monopolist is 50 so what is the total
economic profit here well their total
economic profit is 500 total total
economic economic profit if they
coordinate if they coordinate is 500 if
they coordinate and so they see this and
they say look why don't we agree to each
produce exactly how
of this and we would we would split the
economic profit and to see that let's
just say one firm says okay they both
decide that they're going to produce 25
they're going to get this price for it
up here which was the market price
they're going to get that price for it
they're going to and they're their costs
are right here now we're going to each
individual farm and that makes sense
because this cost is just twice as far
away as this cost and that the dotted
line yellow average total cost for the
market is just a fatter version twice as
fat as the orange line and so each firm
will make this this much economic profit
per unit times 25 units and so each firm
would make this orange area in terms of
economic profit or half of the entire
500 or 250 250 per firm 250 per firm now
let's think about why there is an
incentive for one or both of the firms
to cheat let's say one firm one firm in
particular so the other firm holds at
two at 25 units but the other firm says
hey I like this price I'm already making
economic profit let me produce ten more
units so the other firm says I'm not
going to produce 25 I am going to
produce I am going to produce 35 units
and if that guy produces 35 units and
the other firm the other the other firm
in the market the other dwop a list I
guess we could say it continues to
produce at 25 then the total market
production is now going to be 60 the
total market production is now going to
be 60 now what is the total economic
profit so we can go we can go up the
demand curve right over there that's the
new price that right over there is the
new price the cost per unit is this
right over here and then the number of
units that they're producing is 60 so
the new economic profit is this area the
new economic profit is this area in this
bluish purplish color that I just drew
and we and even visually this is true
looks like the demand curve and the
average total cost curve have gotten
closer together so let's say that this
high
this height right over here is eight and
it's going to be eight eight eight
dollars of economic profit per unit
times sixty units so if they cheat let's
talk about the cheating circumstance if
they cheat
this was coordinate now let's think
about if they cheat now we have sixty
units for the whole market times eight
dollars of economic profit per unit
you're going to have total economic
profit total economic profit profit of
four hundred and eighty your total
economic profit went down and that makes
sense because now is a market you're
producing beyond the point where
marginal revenue is equal to marginal
cost now marginal cost as a market is
higher than marginal revenue and so all
of this all of this is essentially
you're creating economic loss because
each of these incremental units as a
market you're creating the cost is
higher than the revenue or and you have
an economic loss and so that's why your
total economic profit as a market went
down from five hundred to four eighty
but how much is this character how much
is this character going to be making the
one that decided to cheat well he now
has 35 units he's producing thirty five
units and he's getting an economic
profit of eight dollars per unit so he
gets this entire area right over here so
let's multiply let's multiply
thirty-five times eight I'll do it right
over here thirty-five times eight five
times eight is forty three times 8 is 24
plus four is 280 so now the cheating
firm the cheating firm cheat has 280
dollars of economic profit in this
period and then the honest firm or the
fair firm what they're both doing might
be illegal by even attempting to
coordinate the non-cheater I guess I
could call them the non-cheater we'll
have the rest non the non-cheater is
going to have the non-cheater is going
to have the balance of the economic
profit and the total economic profit was
480 the cheaters getting 280 the
non-cheater is only going to get two
hundred so the cheater definitely
benefited by increasing quantity past
that
optimal one he went from 250 to 280 so
it made sense for him it reduced the
total economic profit and it really hurt
and it really hurt the non cheat right
over there